voilà le message est peut-être des
questions j'ai quand votre cerveau à
votre question est ce que je vais pécho
ce soir
j'ai pas besoin de gens pour te dire moi
je te dis que c'est donc
une question ma j'ai ma grand-mère
chérie qui est parti en septembre et il
ya quelques jours j'ai elle a interrompu
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a interrompu
un de mes rêves pour me dire quelque
chose et j'avais conscience dans mon
rêve que c'est n'avait rien à voir avec
mon rêve et comment j'arrive à savoir si
vraiment elle a essayé de rentrer en
contact avec moi ou si c'est juste mon
esprit mon cerveau parce qu'elle me
manque voilà en gros
recrutement le prénom de votre employeur
le présent lucienne adapté lucienne
lucienne lucienne lucienne lucienne
lucienne d'accord
si votre rêve le rêve presque une
réalité
la finissant son chemin pour aller
ailleurs
elle nous de vous dire que rien n'était
facile pour elle l a pas cédé elle a
passé des moments très difficiles
et vous le savez
mais maintenant à trouver la quiétude et
la tranquillité est là pour trouver
quelqu'un qui était cher qu'elle
attendait depuis longtemps
il me dit vous d'hier comme ça je suis
maintenant bien et dites lui dites lui
que là où je me trouve je suis en nba
surtout wii ne pleure pas leur part ne
pleure pas parce que j'ai juste à côté
de toi merci dé parler de moi ça me fait
du bien mais surtout sache que je suis
bien là aussi j'ai trouvé qu'ils tuent
c'est là où vous êtes un des diplômes
voilà
non mais c'est oui gilles veut dire un
truc à jouer oui jean jé je vais vous
poser une question très simple je dois
marié il ya des obstacles en permanence
la question les yeux dans les yeux jean
nouvel jean fin me marier cette année
c'est vrai
ça fait des années qu'on attend près des
voies bien répéter la question jean je
dois marié il ya des obstacles vais-je
enfin me marier cette année avec sato
gens
n'ont pas ce que vous faites deux pas en
avant un pas en arrière oui je suis dit
oui parce que - donnez vous voulez vous
voulez vous voulez mais en fait on vous
pousse aussi vous poussez vous même vous
allez le faire un
jour un petit peu plus tard non mais ça
fait longtemps quand même la jeune femme
était là et ce jour s'interrompt non non
non dans l'année où dans la wii
c'est pas ça qui est un grand voyageur
il va partir en voyage je préfère dire
que c'est beau la vie mais je vais le
retrouver deux personnes après oui
beaucoup de vous ce biais de revoir des
personnes que vous imaginez plus que les
exister ou ethnique est ce que vous
voulez dire ce voyage ce sera quelque
chose d'important pour vous il va partir
longtemps pour savoir pour les
[Rires]
vies parce que j'ai besoin maintenant
aujourd'hui d'une stabilité et d'une
tranquillité à soeur parce que y'en a
marre j'ai fait un petit peu je ça me
faire du pointillisme parce que des fois
vous êtes ayant j'ai fait si je n'aurais
pas dû faire un dessin aujourd'hui c'est
clair c'est net et sans bavure voilà
c'est vrai que c'est que de là vous y
allé et la personne
ça y est merci jean franchement c'est
vrai ce qu'il dit ou pas tout est vrai
c'est incroyable qu'ils ont commencé un
c'est un bonheur je moi je les ai vus
là-bas je veux un truc avec lui tout de
suite j'ai page et je joue avec lui moi
j'ai ma grand mère je pense qu'elle est
tout le temps avec moi et est ce qu'elle
est avec nous là alors dans le public
non mais quelque part je suis persuadé
qu'il ya autour de moi
pense ma grand mère elle est tout le
temps avec moi
elle s'appelait simone d'accord
mais c'est avoir la réponse bah oui la
sonorité oui avez-vous élincourt
puisqu'avant elle dit je n'ai jamais
quitté le sait en plus se retrouver à un
enfant qui est quelqu'un de jeune et
qu'elle est décédée elle a retrouvé
là-bas pour le chercheur es et tu es là
où elle se trouve elle est en peine
plénitude et sérénité elle dit
simplement les choses suivantes
je suis je suis bien j'ai eu un passage
qui était plus difficile et 2 c'est un
moment donné mais là je suis très très
bien et à même de vous répondre vous
sentirez la première intuition qui
viennent la première chose qui vient va
ce sera sa réponse mais le bien est
toujours pris de vous a dit je n'ai
jamais quitté j'ai toujours été là je
retrouvais de personnes dont une amie
qui décide où il va
il a vu si je suis très bien elle dit
oui
et que tu continues est ce que vous
faites
ban devrait pas poser des bombes ciblent
pas si vous n'avez pas tout donné ça
c'est vrai
et de continuer parce que vous avez
il va la publicité il faut en gagner
serait sans rsa faut qu'ils aient
confiance en lui un nom que parfois il
ya un voyage étrange et très loin et
longtemps longtemps à partir par le dial
chaque